The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All
right, are you guys
ready for some more
hardness proofs?
Let's do it.
So today, we start the
universe of 3 partition.
And in general, we're
going to see today
2 plus problems, which
are useful for dealing
with numbers for reducing
to number problems.
Numbers here are going to be
integers for the most part.
Usually in complexity,
it's a lot easier
to think of all your
numbers being integers.
If they're not integers, use
fixed point or rationals,
and then they're
basically integers.
So we're going to talk.
My favorite is 3 partition.
And pretty much all the proofs
we'll do in the number context
will be reduction
from 3 partition.
This is all about
NP-hardness, I should say.
But before we get
to e partition,
I'm going to talk about
another problem, which
is called 2 partition.
First, I'll just have to define
all these problems, which
will take a little while.
Then we'll get to all
the fun reductions.
So in 2 partition,
your given n integers.
We'll call the set
of them capital A
and we'll call the integers
themselves little a sub i--
i from 1 to n, let's say.
And what we'd like to do is
partition them into two groups.
Let's say A1 and A2
equals A of equal sum.
We want the sum of
the integers in A1
to equal the sum of
the integers in A2.
And therefore, they will
equal one half the total sum.
OK, so we just want to find
our choice for each number.
Should it go in A1 or A2?
So this problem is NP-hard.
And it's one of the
original Karp problems.
There's this famous
paper by Karp in 1972.
Before that, there
was a paper by Cook
that proved SAT is NP-complete.
And then Karp wrote a paper
with a zillion-- not literally,
but dozens of NP-hardness
proofs from SAT
to things like 2 partition.
I will not cover the proof here.
If you're interested in
it, read Garey and Johnson.
There's some nice coverage
of this problem and all
the problems we'll be
talking about today.
OK.
As a sideline, I'll mention
there is a generalization
of this problem.
So it's also NP-hard.
Any generalization is
going to be even harder.
But it's useful to know about.
It's called subset sum.
Occasionally it's
easier to think
about subset sum
instead of partition,
although it's a generalization.
So if you can reduce
from subset sum,
you can also reduce
from partition.
And here the set up is similar.
You're given n integers
again, just like before.
And you're given a target sum.
This is one other integer.
We'll call the target sum t.
I'll also call this t.
And what we'd like to do is find
a subset S of A whose sum is t.
OK, this is a strict
generalization here.
You're not given a number
t, but you're essentially
choosing a subset A1, whose
sum equals the sum of A over 2.
So this is really just a
particular choice of t.
This is the general case
where you're given t.
So this is harder than that.
But it's worth knowing about.
In particular, there's
a problem set problem,
the problem set will be
out in a couple of hours.
And it's a little easier
to think about subset sum,
we think.
You don't have to.
All right, so let's
go to 3 partition,
my favorite NP-complete problem.
So start is the same,
given integers A1 up to An.
We're not given a target sum.
What we'd like to
do is partition
them-- partition that set
A into how many pieces?
AUDIENCE: 3.
PROFESSOR: 3.
Nope.
n over 3.
Kind of like 3.
Not quite.
Let's say sets A1,
n over 3 equals
A. I'm using union with a dot
to indicate it's disjoint union.
So that's what a
partition means.
That's redundant.
This is old fashioned notation.
You probably haven't seen it,
but when I was growing up,
that was the
notation of the day.
Then we have n over 3 sets.
Cool, yeah, assume
n is divisible by 3.
Otherwise the answer is no.
And then this is the
easy case of equal sum.
So we want the sum of
each Ai to be equal to t,
which is to the same thing.
They're just going to be the sum
of the A's divided by n over 3.
OK, if this problem were
about partitioning to 3 sets,
it would not be
very interesting.
It would be basically
identical to 2 partition.
With n over 3 sets, things
are quite a bit different.
And we will get to that
difference in a moment.
But first, let me tell
you about some fun
facts about 3 partition.
So we're partitioning
into n over 3 sets,
so you would expect, on
average, most of these sets
will have size 3.
In fact, you could make all
the sets have size exactly 3,
because if you look at the
reduction for this problem,
you can assume that each Ai
is strictly between t over 4
and t over 2.
OK, if you're going to
have a set of numbers
that's summed to exactly
t and each of them
is strictly bigger
than t over 4,
then that means you
can't have 4 of them
because you would
sum to too much.
And they're strictly
less than t over 2.
And you can't just have 2 of
them and hope to get to t.
So you have to have
exactly 3 in every set.
You don't have to assume that.
In some situations, it's
useful to just say, well,
the Ai's are sum sets that
sum to the right things.
Sometimes it useful to
assume that they're triples.
It's up to you
whether you consider
that part of the
problem statement,
to ask for the Ai's
to have size 3 or not.
And it's useful to have both.
In fact, once you
have this, you can
make all the Ai's
very, very close
to t over 3 using a trick,
which we'll see a bunch of times
today.
So let's say you could add--
I'll call it infinity--
to each Ai.
In that case, of course, any
solution that you had before
is still a solution.
Just think of infinity
is a really large number,
something like n
to the 100 times
maximum item in A.
Something like that.
That's really maybe to the
100th power, if you want,
but a really big number.
This will preserve
all solutions,
because all solutions, every
set has size exactly 3.
So if you had 3 times
infinity, they'll
still have the same sums.
And when you do that,
then all the Ai's
are basically equal
to each other,
which means they're
roughly equal to t over 3.
The leading term is
the same for everybody.
And then there's
this little noise,
which was the original integer
that you're adding onto,
that infinity.
So then all the adds
are roughly t over 3.
Cool.
Let me tell you about a
couple related problems
to 3 partition.
And then I'll tell
you why we're even
bothering to talk about two
problems instead of just one.
So next problem has a funny
name, especially when you don't
know what 3 dimensional
matching is,
but we will get to that second.
Don't worry about the
name for the moment.
This is a closely
related problem.
It's really a specialization
of 3 partition.
In this case, we're going to
be given 3 sets of integers.
And what we'd like to
do is-- it's basically
the same problem.
Just think of taking
the union of those
sets, but each of these
sets that we're choosing,
the Ai's, should consist of
one element from A, one element
from B, one element from c.
So how did I formalize that?
Let's say a partition.
This is a disjoint union into
triples, Si, and cross product
ABC.
So you're choosing one from
each of these guys in each Si,
and they should be of equal sum.
And so the sum will be sum of A
plus the sum of B plus sum of C
divided by n , I think,
because there's 3 of them.
Cool.
OK, so almost the
same problem, I just
changed what n was
by a factor of 3.
That's why there's n over
3 here and then here.
But here, we're
specializing in a sense
to say that we're giving
different types of numbers--
the red integers,
the green integers,
and the blue integers.
You have to choose
one of each color.
OK, for fun, let me show you why
this problem is, in some sense,
simpler.
This also gives you
a useful technique
for playing with
these number problems.
So I want to reduce from
this numerical 3 dimensional
matching problem, which
you might also call
the ABC version of 3 partition.
I will reduce it to 3 partition.
So I'm given an
instance, these numbers.
So the basic idea is to take
these numbers just throw them
into one big set, A prime.
But I want to force
this ABC property
that I choose one from each.
Maybe any suggestions how?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Well, I
just have a question.
You define these all as sets.
You can't have
duplicates of an integer?
PROFESSOR: I didn't
say the word set.
I actually meant multiset.
Yeah, so this is a multiset.
Good question.
All of them are multisets.
So it makes the notion of
disunion a little bit weird.
But you know what I mean.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Could you add a
really big number to all
the B's and twice that really
big number to all the C's?
PROFESSOR: OK, add a--
hadn't thought about this.
So add a really big number to
all the B's, and then twice
that big number to all the C's.
And then the target sum would
be three times the big number,
plus--
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry, so
make it three instead,
so you can't do three
things from each side.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So you don't want take two B's
and then that looks like a C.
So maybe you want three
times a big number here
and nine times a
big number here.
Something like that.
I think actually one times
a big number and three
times a big number would do it.
Yeah, cool.
So the way I did it in the
notes was adding a small number,
but either way, it works.
Let's do it with the big
number, because that's fun.
So we will construct, I'll
call it A prime to consist
of a overall little a and big
A. And then we'll say a plus--
usually big number I
write with a capital B,
but that's not very good
because we already have a couple
of B's.
So I'll call it X. Or I
should call it infinity
for consistency.
So for each b and B, I
will add infinity to it.
And then c is going to be is
3 times-- let's do 4 times
infinity.
It makes me feel a
little safer somehow,
because we're constructing
a set of size 3.
So if you take 3 of these,
I worry that looks like a C.
It's not enough,
but we'll be safe.
Why not?
We can choose pretty
big numbers here.
So happy?
No?
AUDIENCE: You might be
able to do a couple A's
in a single set.
The set should be small, because
they're not-- [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
a is our problem.
You could maybe do
more than 3 total.
So let's do 1 infinity,
then get a proper eraser.
It's a good thing we have Sarah
here to correct our proofs.
3 infinity 9.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
enough, because then we need--
PROFESSOR: 6 would be bad,
because then 2 of these
would be 1 of those.
AUDIENCE: 13 infinities
on [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so this
means the new target sum should
be the old target sum, which
was the sum of these divided
by n, plus 13 infinity.
AUDIENCE: Isn't infinity
a function of the n's?
PROFESSOR: Infinity
I should define.
Let's make it, I think,
just like 10 times max
of A ought to do it.
You could be it as
a function of n.
I don't think that's necessary
here, because all of our sets
are size 3.
But if you're doing something
like this for 2 partition,
you'd want to multiply
by n or n squared.
This is a common trick to
do this kind of scaling
or offsets or things like that.
Instead of infinity
here, you can
write epsilon, where epsilon
is much smaller than 1.
I think that would also work.
And that's what's done in this.
AUDIENCE: So we just
make it the max of the A
as opposed to A prime?
PROFESSOR: Oops, this should
probably be max of ABC.
Yeah, you can't make
it max of A prime.
That would be cyclic.
That infinity would
actually be infinite.
Good.
So I think that works.
There are things to
check here, obviously.
We need to check
that whenever we
have a solution to
the original instance,
we have a solution
to this instance.
That's pretty clear.
You just take the same choices
of the Ai's, Bi's, and Ci's.
And the infinities will
always add up to 13.
The tricky part is
to show that if you
have a solution to this
3 partition instance,
you can convert that back into
a solution to the numerical 3
dimensional matching instance.
And that's where
you essentially want
to show that the infinities
can be treated algebraically.
Because they're so
huge, you could never
construct an infinity
in another way.
But I'll leave that as an
exercise to actually proof,
because we're not really going
to use this problem too much.
You're welcome to,
maybe on problem sets,
maybe on open problems
it would be good.
But most the time, I would
say we use 3 partition.
I want you to know about
this in particular,
because it's related to
another problem, which is
called 3 dimensional matching.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is the
assumption that the Ai
is all a cardinality of 3 built
into the problem specification
here?
PROFESSOR: You get a choice.
You can either make
this part of the problem
specification or not.
It won't matter.
AUDIENCE: OK, well I
think in this case,
if you don't know
the problem specs,
can you take 12
A's for something?
And then you get 12
infinities and then
they add up to another infinity?
PROFESSOR: Yes,
we definitely want
to take this as part
of the specification
for this reduction.
Yeah.
Good point.
OK, so here's a problem.
You've probably heard
of the matching problem.
Let's say the perfect matching
problem is you're given a graph
and you want to find a set
of edges which are disjoint,
meaning no two edges
share a vertex, that
covers all the vertices.
So if you have n
vertices, you'd like
to find n over 2 edges that
are disjoint from each other.
That's perfect matching.
You might call it 2
dimensional matching,
because an edge has 2 ends.
3 dimensional matching takes
place in a hyper graph.
And in this case, it's going
to be a tripartite hyper graph.
You may not have seen
hyper graphs before.
They're just like
graphs, but edges
can have more than 2 endpoints.
In this case, they
will have exactly 3.
So let's say the vertices are
A disjoining in B disjoining
in C. And let's say they
all have like size n.
And the hyper edge is E.
OK, maybe it's worth
drawing a picture.
So you have this set A, set B--
they're all the same size-- set
C. And an edge might look like
this or like this or so on.
OK, you take one from each.
And then your goal is to
find n disjoint edges.
If we find that many
and they're disjoint,
that means they will
cover all of the vertices.
Every vertex will be hit
by exactly one hyper edge.
OK, so this is the 3 dimensional
version of bipartite matching,
I guess.
There's also the
non-bipartite version.
For extra completeness,
there's something
called exact cover by 3 sets,
3 meaning the cardinality.
This is called X3C.
You do see 3DM
and X3C frequently
in the literature and
especially in Garey and Johnson.
So they're good
problems to know about.
Here is sort of the generalized
version, where you're given
non-tripartite, just a
3 uniform hyper graph.
3 uniform just means every
edge has cardinality 3.
And your goal is to find--
let's say it has n vertices--
n over 3 disjoin hyper edges.
OK, many times the
almost same problem.
How do these relate?
Well, certainly if you take
a numerical 3 dimensional
matching problem, that is a 3
dimensional matching problem.
You can convert it
into a graph like this.
You're just forgetting the
fact that there's numbers.
But then when you
draw the edge, you
draw one of these hyper edges
exactly when Ai plus Bi plus Ci
equals the targets sum.
So numerical 3
dimensional matching
is a special case of 3
dimensional matching.
Occasionally it's
useful to start
from 3 dimensional matching.
Not for number problems though.
If you have a number problem,
you like the numerical version.
Personally I prefer 3 partition,
but these two are pretty close.
We saw one connection
between them.
Exact cover by 3 sets
is, in some sense,
even more general than
3 dimensional matching.
Yeah, it is more general,
because tripartite hyper graph
like this is 3 uniform.
So this is a strict
generalization of that.
But they all appear
somewhat, so I
thought it'd good for
you to know about them.
Again, 3 partition is
where the action is.
All right, let me go
back to this issue of 2
partition versus 3 partition.
These are the two main
problems I want to talk about.
And they relate to an important
distinction in NP-hardness,
which is weak versus
strong NP-hardness.
So there are two
types of NP-hardness
for number problems.
If your input is a graph,
these two notions are the same,
so you don't need
to worry about it.
But when your problem
has integers as input,
then there are two types.
Weakly NP-hard
is, in some sense,
the type you
already know, if you
think about it in the right
way, in the intended way.
We haven't been super
formal about how
numbers getting encoded, but
usually we think of NP-hardness
in terms of how
hard your problem is
in terms of the encoding
size, which we usually call
n, the encoding of your input.
OK, so in the usual
form, what this means
is that you allow numbers
to have exponential value,
because even when their
value is exponential,
the encoding of that
value is polynomial.
Coding length of such a number
is, if you read it in binary,
that's log base 2 of the number
if the number is 2 to the n
to the c, which is our
definition of exponential.
That's going to be n to the c.
And that's polynomial.
OK, for here, I'm
going to let n be
the number of numbers to
avoid circular definitions
or something.
So I'm saying there are
n different numbers.
If each of them is at most
2 to the n to the c in value
and they're integers, then I can
encode them in this many bits.
And that's a polynomial
number of bits.
So I consider that a
reasonable encoding.
And sometimes that's just fine.
But there's a
stronger notion, which
is really useful, especially
for a lot of problems
we will see today
and next class, which
is called strongly NP-hard.
And this is NP-hard even when
your problem is restricted
to numbers of polynomial value.
So polynomial here
is with respect to n
and is the number of
integers-- number of numbers.
OK, so strongly NP-hard is
stronger than weakly NP-hard.
If you're NP-hard even
when your numbers are
only polynomial in
size, then of course
your NP-hard when
you allow the numbers
to be as large as exponential.
This is a weaker
constraint on the problem.
So to cut to the chase,
2 partition up here
and subset sum are
weakly NP-hard.
And if you believe that
the P does not equal NP,
then it's not strongly NP-hard.
That's the best we can
hope for, whereas 3
partition in every other
problem we talked about
is strongly NP-hard.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
What do you mean
exactly by numbers
having exponential value?
PROFESSOR: So again, exponential
is like 2 to the n to the c. n
is the number of
numbers in your input.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So that's what I allow.
I mean, this is what would
be allowed if you didn't say
anything, if you interpret
complexity theory in a way
that I haven't
necessarily told you,
but generally you want to
assume that all your inputs are
reasonably encoded
in an efficient way
that most possible input
strings are valid inputs.
And so if you're encoding,
then in particular,
you should encode
your numbers in
binary or ternary or quaternary
or hexadecimal-- anything
bigger than one is good.
OK?
And you should know
if you're writing
that number, don't use unary.
But today we're going
to use unary a lot.
So this is the same thing
as saying encode in unary.
Strong NP-hardness
is like saying, well,
my problem is so
hard that even if I
encode my numbers in unary,
it's still hard in the resulting
input size.
The input size would
be if you write down
every number in unary and
add up all the numbers.
That's your input size.
3-partition is that hard.
2-partition is not.
OK?
So if you can prove strong
NP-hardness, you should.
It's better.
If you can only prove
weak NP-hardness, it's OK.
It's still hard.
Now you should know, there
are corresponding notions
on the algorithm side.
So let's talk about
that a little bit.
So corresponding algorithms
are-- there are actually
three of them.
The main ones are
pseudopolynomial
and weakly polynomial.
Sorry.
The weaklies are unrelated to
each other, but that's life.
There's also a notion called
strongly polynomial-- unrelated
to strongly NP-hard.
Well, there you go.
OK.
So weakly polynomial is the
usual notion of polynomial
I should mention.
When I say I have a polynomial
time algorithm, what you mean
is weakly, meaning
that, let's say,
I'll write it as polynomial in
n-- the number of integers--
and let's say, log of
the largest integer--
largest number in the input.
OK?
That's a reasonable
encoding size.
You write them in binary.
You add them all up.
So you'd multiply
that by n or whatever.
And the polynomial in that
value is weakly polynomial.
Pseudopolynomial
you omit the log.
OK.
So I want polynomial on
n and the largest number.
And strongly polynomial, you
omit that term altogether.
So you just polynomial
n the number of numbers.
OK?
So there's a different world
of algorithms which we're not
going to talk about
here, which is weakly
polynomial algorithms versus
strongly polynomial algorithms.
I'm not aware of any
lower bounds about that,
but there are famous
open questions like,
can you solve linear programming
in strongly polynomial time?
We don't know.
There's no hardness
notion there.
So we're not going to talk
about it any more than that.
What we care about more
is this distinction
between pseudopolynomial.
This is polynomial when the
numbers are written in unary,
and this polynomial when the
numbers are written in binary.
So these two notions correspond
to these two notions.
So in particular, if you
believe p does not equal NP,
then weakly NP-hard
means there is
no weakly polynomial algorithm.
But there might be a
pseudopolynomial algorithm.
Strongly NP-hard means there's
no M polynomial algorithm,
and so therefore there's no
weakly polynomial algorithm.
Adam.
AUDIENCE: So the difference
between weakly polynomial
and strongly polynomial is that
we don't even necessarily give
ourselves time to read all the
numbers and put it in binary?
PROFESSOR: I didn't want
to get too much into models
of computation, but the
model of computation
here is that you're allowed to
read an entire number in one
time step.
So if you've taken 6851
Advanced Data Structures,
this is like a word RAM.
So that's the only reason
this would be reasonable.
Otherwise you couldn't
read the input.
That would be pretty hard.
So the model is you could
take a constant number
of your numbers, do
something with them,
output another number
of the same type
roughly in constant time.
And you want to do a polynomial
number of such steps, usually
arithmetic operations.
Here you don't have to be
so careful about the model
because any reasonable
encoding, you
could read it and do
whatever you want with it.
If you don't care about the
exponent in the polynomial,
like all models are equivalent.
If you believe the Strong Church
[INAUDIBLE] Thesis-- anyway.
This one you have to
be a little bit more
careful what the model is.
Good.
So let me draw my
favorite diagram
with the difficulty axis.
But now instead of p,
I'm going to distinguish
between weakly polynomial,
pseudopolynomial,
and strongly polynomial.
So these things are pseudopoly.
These things are weakly poly.
And these things
are strongly poly.
This is on the
algorithm side, upper
bounds-- be on the left of
the particular position.
And then on the hardness side
we have-- let me use red.
It's more dramatic.
This thing is weakly NP-hard.
This is if p does
not equal NP then
you're strictly to the
right of pseudopoly.
So there's no
pseudopoly problem.
There's also weakly NP-hard.
And then strongly
NP-hard excludes
even a weakly polynomial
algorithm, so strictly
to the right of that position.
So obviously, strongly
NP-hard is a better result
because it's smaller
than this class.
But for example, 2-partition,
which is only weakly NP-hard,
has a pseudopolynomial
algorithm.
You've probably even seen
one in your algorithms class
if you've ever done
anything like Knapsack
as a dynamic program.
That is a dynamic program
probably originally done
for a 2-partition.
OK.
So that problem is
somewhere right in here.
Weakly NP-hard-- whoops.
AUDIENCE: I think the
diagram that's is backward,
but I don't--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Diagram is--
AUDIENCE: If a
problem is strongly
polynomial it ends [INAUDIBLE]
a weakly polynomial.
PROFESSOR: So the
middle one's right.
Thank you.
That seemed funny.
But strongly polynomial
is this tightest class.
That's the best result.
And pseudopoly is
the worst result.
Did I get my arrows
in the right place?
AUDIENCE: You've
got to shift over.
PROFESSOR: Shift over one.
Strongly NP-hard.
Whoops.
So weakly NP-hard is here.
Strongly NP-hard is there.
OK.
Cool.
So let's check.
So 2-partition
should be pseudopoly,
so left of this line,
but weakly NP-hard still
right of that line.
That looks good.
So this is 2-partition.
3-partition is out here.
I mean, I'd draw
this is a region,
but it's more like a
point in my old diagram
because 3-partitions
are actually E and NP.
So it's strongly NP-complete.
So it's like right
at the edge there.
Anyway, there's no
pseudopolynomial algorithm
for 3-partition,
unlike 2-partition.
That's the point of all that.
Let's do some.
Shall we?
NP-hardcore time.
So that'll be over here.
OK.
The first reduction is
going to be pretty--
AUDIENCE: May I ask a
question before we move on?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So why is there
a no corresponding notion
for problems are not numeric?
Like why can't for a
graph problem we say,
well, we're going to examine
this graph problem assuming
we're using an inefficient
encoding of our graph
to see how hard it is?
PROFESSOR: I guess you could
try to define this in terms
for graphs, but I
don't think there
is such an obvious
inefficient notion of graphs.
I mean, the obvious
inefficient notion
is like use a matrix instead
of an adjacency list.
But that's polynomially
equivalent.
So I mean there certainly
are other notions
you could imagine, but there
aren't any in the literature.
All right.
So just to warn you, the
first reduction we do
is going to be a
little bit trivial.
So don't get too excited yet.
But this is where
3-partition comes from.
Then we'll do lots of cool ones.
So multiprocessor scheduling.
Let's say I have n jobs, and
they have completion times.
And that's it.
You can start them
whenever you want.
And then on the
other hand, I have
p processors to run those jobs.
Each processor is
sequential and identical.
So the model is you
assign jobs to processors.
Job can only be
on one processor,
and it runs to completion.
Then it can run
another job, and so on.
My goal-- I'll state
the decision version--
is to finish all jobs in
time less than or equal to t.
OK?
So I claim this problem is
NP-hard of some variety.
Let's start with a
reduction from partition.
Sorry.
Partition is a synonym
for 2-partition.
Usually we omit the two.
So reduction from partition.
This problem over here.
So now I'm given some integers.
I want to split them
in half basically.
Any suggestions
on what I could do
to turn that into a
multiprocessor scheduling
problem?
AUDIENCE: Two processors.
PROFESSOR: Two processors.
Yeah.
p equals 2.
That is the reduction.
I guess, technically, I also
have to specify what t is,
but it's over there.
So you set t to be the
sum of the A's over 2.
And you don't change A.
You just leave it alone.
So you just feed in the same
A i's into this problem.
And that is 2-partition.
OK.
Let's do a reduction
from-- so now we
know the problem is at
least weakly NP-hard,
but in fact, it is strongly
NP-hard, because we
can reduce from 3-partition.
What do you do?
AUDIENCE: P equals n over 3.
PROFESSOR: P equals n over 3.
That's it.
You set t accordingly.
Sum of the A's over p.
Done.
OK.
So this problem
comes from the paper
that introduces
3-partition, which
is by Gary and Johnson, the
same people who wrote the book.
So, I mean, this
basically is 3-partition.
That's why they cared about it.
But here's a practical
motivation for it.
Cool.
Let's do something
more interesting.
And I kind of want a projector.
Any questions about--
I think you've
asked enough questions
about pseudopoly,
weakly poly, strongly
poly, as I erase them.
Don't forget them.
But I think for
the rest of today
we're just going to be doing
strong polynomial reductions
from 3-partition.
I think next class we
might do some weak ones,
but today we're going
to really use the fact
that it-- use the strongness.
And you'll see why,
because we really
want to encode some
numbers in unary.
OK.
Let's start with a
problem-- rectangle packing.
And this is going to lead us
to a whole bunch of other types
of packing problems.
So this is what you might
call packing rectangles
into a rectangle.
So I'm given n rectangles, and
I'm given a target rectangle.
So when I say I'm given a
rectangle, what I really mean
is I'm given the dimensions--
the width and the height--
as integers.
We are usually going to assume
all our numbers are integers,
as I said.
Do they fit?
So what I'd like, in a solution,
is to rotate and translate
the given rectangles
so that they're
disjointed from each
other, they can't overlap,
and they all fit inside
the target rectangle.
All right.
So this might be the
target rectangle.
And then, I don't
know, maybe this
is my set of rectangles
appropriately packed.
So here maybe the answer is yes.
If they don't fit inside
the target rectangle,
the answer is no.
This problem is
strongly NP-hard,
but I'm pretty sure we don't
know whether it's E and NP.
So there are lots
of open problems.
I don't mean to indicate
everything is known.
I should double check that
this is definitely not known,
but I'm pretty sure it's open.
Because of this
rotation issue there
are kind of a lot of
things to worry about.
So it's not clear
how efficiently
you can encode a solution.
Maybe you need a ton
of bits of precision
to say how things are rotated.
Here they're all rotated
at the same angle.
They may not be.
Who knows.
So we will consider a special
case, which is exact packing.
This also makes for a
stronger hardness result.
So exact packing means
there are no gaps.
None of this stuff.
That's forbidden.
So if you have no
gaps and you look
at a corner of the
rectangle, that
must mean there is a
rectangle right there filling
the corner, which means
there's no rotation.
Well, you could rotate
by multiples of 90.
But just know there
are four rotations.
Well, I guess two for
rectangles-- integer
times 90 degrees.
So then the problem is an
NP, because also then you
can show at that
point-- because you
have integer rectangles packing
into an integer rectangle--
by induction, the
translations are integers.
Therefore, there are
succinct encodings of them.
OK.
We don't have to do this,
but just to point out,
this is one way to make
the problem in E and NP.
Now they are
assisting solutions.
So we're going to prove
both of these problems
are strongly NP-hard.
I think I'll skip
the weak NP-hardness
proof because it's not really
any harder-- no pun unintended.
So let's go there.
So the basic idea again, we're
reducing from 3-partition.
So that means we're
given, on any instance
of 3-partition, n integers.
We want to represent those
integers as rectangles.
So kind of the obvious way to
do that is we take each a i
and we convert it
into a rectangle.
Let's say it's a i by 1.
That seems pretty obvious.
This is what you might call
the a i gadget, since we're
going to map this feature
of our given instance
to this feature of our
constructed instance.
All that would be
left at this point
is what is the target rectangle,
which I didn't give a name.
So let me call the
target rectangle
B. I think that's what
I used in my notes.
Yep.
So let's say B is going
to be a rectangle.
What is the height
of the rectangle?
AUDIENCE: n over 3.
PROFESSOR: n over 3.
Yes.
Right.
And then the width?
AUDIENCE: The sum
divided by n over 3.
PROFESSOR: The target sum, t.
Cool.
So the intent is that the
rectangles will look something
like this.
And always, however, if I
fit three in here-- or maybe
I could do more
than three, but we
know that won't happen with the
actual 3-partition instances
we get, because we can
assume there are always
three of them-- but anyway,
we're not constraining
there are only three.
You put in however
many rectangles.
Add up to exactly
the target sum.
Boom.
You've got the target sum.
And there's just enough
space for all of them
if you pack them this way.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Shouldn't we
specify that the a i rectangle
is a i times n over 3 plus
1 to make sure that we
can't accidentally rotate them?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So part of my confusion in
drawing this-- and I worry--
is you could take one of these
rectangles and rotate it.
And then this
reduction is wrong.
So this reduction is wrong.
So I will cheat and
make this epsilon,
and then multiply
this by epsilon.
This is one way to fix it.
Of course, now I have
to scale everything up
by 1 over epsilon.
And I have to tell
you what epsilon is.
You were suggesting
some multiple of n,
which is a good suggestion.
I think as long as we make
this much smaller than 1,
then it's not
possible to rotate,
because these guys
are length at least 1,
because they're integers.
So if I tried to rotate, it has
to be a multiple 90 degrees.
So I think as long as this
is strictly less than 1,
we are OK.
I didn't change the
intended solution.
I just made everything narrower.
And so I just need to set
epsilon less than 3 over n.
It would be that inequality.
But I want integers, so I
should scale everything up
by n over 3.
So just multiply all the numbers
by n over 3, and you're done.
In fact, you can be
a little simpler.
And I drew this
diagram long ago,
so I might as well
show it to you.
You can just add n over
3 to all your integers.
That will also work,
under the assumption
that you can only take three
numbers and add them up.
Then you will always be adding
3 times n over 3 horizontally.
So they a i's here
are the yellow part
of these rectangles,
and then we're
just adding this fixed
n over 3 to all of them.
So this is a 4, a 4, a
4, a 4, a 5, 5, 5, 6, 7.
And that happens to
be a positive instance
of 3-partition.
There is a solution.
This is one way to do it.
So we're just adding
n overall here,
because we have
3 times n over 3.
And the length of these
is always smaller.
Rotation should not be possible,
because each of these guys
is going to be length
strictly larger than n
over 3 because we add
an integer to n over
3-- a positive integer-- and
the height here is n over 3.
So that just barely works.
Same thing, more
or less, just this
is scaling by a
multiplicative factor here.
We're doing an additive
thing, because we
have this luxury of
knowing there are
three items in every triple.
Cool.
Rectangle packet.
Question.
AUDIENCE: This is a
question about 3-partition.
Is it assuming that they
are positive integers?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
All the integers are positive.
You don't have to, but we can.
So we will.
Makes our life a lot easier.
Other questions?
OK.
Time for some puzzles.
So I think I'll show you
some real life puzzles first.
There's this notion of
an edge-matching puzzle,
which goes back to the 1890s.
I believe this one is from
the late 1890s, early 1900s.
So it's one of the older ones.
At least when I was growing
up, we had these puzzle
all over the place.
So what's going on here is
you have physical triangles,
and these half frogs are drawn
on the edges of the triangles.
And your goal is to pack
all of these triangles
into the big triangle.
That's easy.
It's a regular triangulation.
But you need to half
frogs to match up.
I don't know.
The hind end of the white-- I'm
sorry-- yellow-speckled frog
matches the front end of the
yellow-black-speckled frog,
as drawn here.
This is a valid solution, but
if I rotated this tile 120
degrees, it's not
a valid solution
even though it's all hinds
matching to fronts and so on.
OK?
Rules clear?
So these are
edge-matching puzzles.
This is formulated
in a different way.
This is not a valid solution.
The goal is to get these
colors to all match up.
So in general, you can think of
there being a color on an edge.
And here it happens to be
composed of these two colors.
And it would have to
match both of the colors
on the other side.
So it's essentially like
having a color on each edge.
Here, we also have a
color on each edge,
but we also have a sign, which
is the front or the hind part
of the frog.
There's the yellow frog, the
red frog, the green frog,
the orange frog.
So in general, we're
going to formulate this.
I'll get over here.
OK.
There are many types of these
puzzles I'll try to capture.
It's not exactly
either one of those.
If you've ever studied
something called Wang tiles,
this is exactly that model.
So I'll just throw
in the word there.
But what we have
are n unit squares.
Those are called the tiles.
Each one has four
colors-- a, b, c, d.
So one per edge.
And you are also given
a target rectangle.
It's going to be integer,
because these are unit squares.
And you want to pack-- probably
exactly pack so there are not
going be any gaps-- the squares
into the rectangle with colors
matching.
So whenever I have two
squares that share an edge,
the color that's
written here better
be the same color
that's written there.
Those are the rules.
If you're on the
boundary, no restriction.
But if you're an interior
edge, you restrict in that way.
OK?
This actually closely
matches what is currently
maybe the most famous
edge-matching puzzle called
Eternity II.
This one is still unsolved.
Well, the creator
has a solution.
And if you ever find it, or one
of the many other solutions--
who knows-- you
win $2 million US.
So time to get rich.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, yeah.
I guess that's the way
to make the most money
is first solve p equals NP.
And then solve
Eternity II, I guess.
But you could easily solve this
puzzle without p equals NP.
There are actually a lot of
almost solutions out there.
I believe this is
one of the leaders.
This guy, Louis
Verhaad, got-- so this
is a complete solution
with all the pieces,
but not all the edges match.
So it's hard to find
them, but here's one,
for example, that mismatches.
So I didn't explain, but
everything is a square tile
here, and there's a
different shape and color.
But it's basically a color from
a mathematical perspective.
Have to match them all up.
Here he got 467 matches
out of the 480 edges.
And that won him
already $10,000.
And I believe it's found
with a computer-aided search.
AUDIENCE: Is that--
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES].
AUDIENCE: That's
not the person who--
PROFESSOR: I don't
know for sure.
I would guess that
it's Louis's daughter.
Here's a different
almost solution
where there are some missing
tiles but everything matches.
And then at the bottom
of his web page,
you should check it out.
It's funny.
It says, "And here is a
solution to Eternity II."
I looked at this
for a long time,
and I was like I don't see any
edge matches, but you guys are
smart, so you
probably know there's
one other cheat you could
possibly do in this puzzle.
AUDIENCE: Add Different tiles?
PROFESSOR: Add different tiles?
Maybe.
Although these are
nicely-printed tiles.
So I would guess he bought two
sets and just mixed some parts.
I wrote a program to
check yes, indeed,
some tiles are repeated here.
I forget exactly how many.
10 or 20 or something.
It's still pretty cool.
It looks like it's done.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: But there's no
complete actual solution
using each piece exactly once.
It's probably clear
here, but you only
get one version of each square.
OK.
So there's your motivation
for solving edge-matching.
So you might wonder, oh, can
I solve it in polynomial time?
And the answer is no
unless p equals NP.
And here we're going to use
essentially rectangle packing
and this reduction.
So how could I--
again, we're going
to reduce from 3-partition.
How could I convert a
number a i into something
like a rectangle
using edge-matching?
I should probably copy over
the one that we had in the end,
which was a i goes to
n over 3 plus a i by 1,
because we want integers.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So you make it so
that there is sort of one color,
and that's for
[INAUDIBLE] most things.
And that's [INAUDIBLE]
kind of on the outside
of each rectangle.
And then put together
each rectangle.
If you need like-- if the
rectangle is like a i by 1,
you're going to need a i
squares, such that there's
like one color for
that rectangle that
is only used to join the other
squares of that rectangle.
PROFESSOR: Good.
So we're going to convert this
something by one rectangle
into something
different squares.
And we're just going to
sub-divide like that.
And we're going to
surround all these edges
with the same color.
That will work.
AUDIENCE: And the interior
edges [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The interior
edges-- all right.
So we're going to
take a i, and we're
going to convert it into-- OK.
Don't make me draw all of them--
the width here, let's say,
will be n over 3 plus a i.
And we're going to use
a special color-- I'll
call it black-- on the outside.
And this color I'm
going to call--
I need some red so it's slightly
visible-- I'm going to call i.
This is going to be a
different color for each a i.
This will require a
little bit more work.
You could also use a different--
you could use i1, i2, i3--
but I would really force this
to go together in this way.
If I'm trying to be
conservative on colors--
only use n of them-- then
I will put those all i.
And then as long as none of
these matched to the boundary,
I'm OK.
I guess even if I
used the i1, i2, i3,
it's possible some of
those match the boundary.
And then weird
stuff could happen.
But as long as
all these i colors
match up with each other, you
have to build this rectangle.
And then we don't care about
how the rectangles are assembled
with respect to each other.
So we're basically simulating
this reduction rectangle
packing.
OK.
The one I have drawn here
is slightly different.
I don't remember why
we did it this way.
This is [INAUDIBLE] work with
Marty Dumaine, the cameramen.
And here, just I guess to
be as simple as possible,
we made the width of each
of the rectangles just a i.
That has a problem
that you could rotate.
But to prevent rotation,
we use a different color
horizontal and vertical.
So the top edges and
the bottom edges all
have the colored percent sign.
I think this is a limitation
of the drawing program
I was using at
the time actually.
And dollar signs on the
left and right side.
And then we're going
to build frame.
This is what you might call
infrastructure for the proof.
This is one gadget happens.
You just execute it once.
This we execute for
each of the a i's.
We're just going to have
one copy of this big frame.
The goal the frame is to hide
the boundary so that none
of these tiles could
match with the boundary,
because when they
match the boundary then
you're breaking a rectangle
in half and bad things
could happen.
So instead, what
we're going to do
is all of these capital
letters on the outside--
and I ran out of letters and
used a couple of symbols--
appear exactly once
in the reduction.
So they can't
match anyone, which
means they have to
be on the boundary.
So those guys have to
And then all these other
colors appear exactly twice,
so you have to join these tiles
together in exactly this way.
And now the boundary is gone.
And we have set up dollar
signs on the left side
and the right side, and
percent signs on the top
and the bottom sides.
In reality, these would
be whatever t wide and n
over 3 tall.
This is just some
different notation.
And that's it.
Now you're simulating
rectangle packing.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Why do you need
two rows at the bottom?
PROFESSOR: So this two rows
is to indicate, for whatever
reason, because in
edge-matching puzzles,
usually the target shape is
not a rectangle, but a square.
And we wanted the
stronger result
at packing unit
squares into a square
with edge-matching
results E as NP-hard.
So the point here is
you just add however
many rows or columns you
need to make it a square.
Yep.
Good question.
Jason?
AUDIENCE: So your different
symbols, I believe,
are also to let you build this
into the rectangle later on.
Otherwise, you'll run into
issues with rotating things.
PROFESSOR: We'll get there.
Yeah.
So I have different
symbols here and here
in order to prevent rotation.
That's right.
Instead of making them longer.
I could've, instead,
made these longer
like we had with
the rectangle thing,
but I guess, at the
time, I wasn't thinking
of teaching a class about this.
So I didn't reuse my previous
reduction for this one.
But oh, well.
Yeah.
But the reason there are
dollar signs in there
like red or some actual
color is because probably
black and white printing
was more common then.
OK.
Cool.
That was one puzzle.
And now key point.
What if we did this
reduction from partition?
So with partition, instead
of having n over three groups
here, we just have two groups?
And same thing.
Why not do that?
AUDIENCE: So that would
be a weakly NP-hard.
PROFESSOR: That would be
a weak NP-hard reduction.
Now, this problem here--
edge-matching puzzle,
n unit squares of four
colors-- are there
any numbers in this problem?
AUDIENCE: 4
PROFESSOR: Other than 4 and n?
Are there any numbers
that are inputs?
AUDIENCE: I guess
the colors have
to be represented as numbers.
PROFESSOR: The
colors do you have
to be represented as numbers,
but this is sort of a sideline.
Usually, when we're
talking about colors,
all we care about is whether
the colors are equal or not.
So you don't normally
think of those as numbers.
You can think of
them as vertices
in a graph or something.
I mean, they're more like
combinatorial objects.
You're never adding
two colors together.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The other
point is that the number
of different colors
that you can get
is at most 4 times n
because [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: The number of
colors is in most 4 times n.
Yeah, you could write down
a color as 2 to 2 to the n,
but why?
It's supposed to be
an efficient encoding.
So there are really
no numbers here.
So it doesn't even make
sense to say this problem is
strongly NP-hard.
But even worse, if I
started with 2-partition,
and I did this reduction exactly
as drawn but not as tall,
I could still make it a square,
but everything would break.
Because for 2-partition to
be hard, those numbers--
the a i's-- have to be
exponential in value.
If I have an
exponential value a i,
when I convert it
into a rectangle,
or actually I convert it
into a bunch of tiles,
I will have
exponentially many tiles.
This construction will
be of exponential size.
So I will get exponentially
many different colors
on the boundary.
So that's very bad.
Even if you're
clever and you say,
oh, well, these tiles
are all the same,
so maybe I'll encode
them efficiently
and say there's an exponentially
many of this one tile.
The ones in the boundary
are all different.
So it's not a valid reduction.
You should always
take a problem that's
supposed to run
in polynomial time
and produce a result
of polynomial size.
So if I start with
something where
the input is
polynomial size but it
has exponentially
large a i's, I'd
get an exponential size puzzle,
which is boring to solve.
I don't know.
It's not a valid
NP-hardness reduction.
This is why we want to
start from 3-partition.
Because then I know even
if what I'm doing here
is representing
the a i's in unary.
I take the a i and
said, OK, I'm going
to have that many square tiles.
But that is exactly
unary representation.
And we know with 3-partition
that will have polynomial size.
And so we're good.
This is why we care
about strong NP-hardness
so much, because a lot
of puzzles you can only
represent numbers in unary.
Then you're forced to
work with 3-partition.
OK.
Next puzzle is signed
edge-matching puzzles
like the lizards.
Suppose same set up,
but now the colors
aren't supposed to be equal.
They're supposed
to be opposites.
So I'm just going to
modify this diagram,
and I will use capital letters
to denote tails of lizards,
and lowercase letters to
represent heads of lizards.
And little b only
matches capital B.
It does not match little b.
You can't put two heads
together or two tails together.
Well, you can
reduce these things,
which are called unsigned
edge-matching puzzles,
to these things,
which are called
signed edge-matching puzzles,
with this easy gadget.
If you have a tile
with, let's just say,
colors ABCD-- some
of them might be
equal-- I'm going to replace
that one tile with these four
tiles and scale everything
up by a factor of 2-- scale
the target shape
by a factor of 2.
These colors appear exactly once
with each sign, and so again,
because there's a frame and
all the boundary is eaten up,
you're forced to match
these guys to each other.
And therefore you're forced
to make this 2 by 2 tile.
And so that 2 by
2 tile is supposed
to represent this 1 by 1 tile.
And the claim is signs
no longer matter,
because we put little a, big
A, little b, big B, little c
big C, and so on.
So if I took another
tile like over here,
and it has something
like capital D,
lowercase d, that's
going to match
with this lowercase b lowercase
b, if and only if b equals d.
So if the original
colors are equal,
the resulting colors will
be equal and opposite.
So it'll be the same
letter of the alphabet,
but with opposite signs, and
so everything will match up,
because this capital
letter match here,
and this lowercase
letter will match there.
Is that clear?
So it really becomes
the same puzzle,
and this one's going to be
solvable only if this one is.
So we get strong--
well, just NP-hardness
of signed edge-matching puzzles.
Cool.
Next puzzle.
These were all on
the same paper.
It was a fun paper.
This is even older.
Jigsaw puzzles.
This is not the
oldest jigsaw puzzles.
It's one of the newest.
It's our course poster
turned into a jigsaw puzzle.
If you want to make your own
jigsaw puzzles, go there.
They go back to the
1760s when they were made
with jigsaws, hence the name.
But basically, we
have square pieces,
and each side of
the-- I'll assume
that's a special kind
of jigsaw puzzle,
most common-- each edge
can either be straight.
That means it's on the boundary.
It can be a pocked or a tab.
And each pocket and tab is
slightly differently shaped,
although maybe not on this
picture, usually they are.
I'm going to allow that some
of the pockets and the tabs
have the same shape.
That's what you might
call ambiguous mates.
Most jigsaw puzzles
sold in the world do not
have ambiguous mates,
but let's say they do.
And to make it
NP-hardcore, there
is no image on the pieces.
It's just a white puzzle.
Now those are sold.
You can buy all white or are
all single color puzzles.
But usually they don't
have ambiguous mates.
That's like the ultimate combo.
If you don't assume
either of those things,
then the problem is easy.
So we don't care about that.
But our paper is about how
to solve jigsaw puzzles
in the practical case.
But in our situation,
I mean, that basically
is edge-matching
puzzles with science.
This is actually probably why
I care about signed puzzles
the most.
I have lowercase letters.
Those are going to
correspond to pockets.
I have uppercase letters.
Those are going to
correspond to tabs.
And of course, a tab
must meet a pocket,
same as a lowercase letter
must be an uppercase letter.
And so that is the same thing.
I would like my
target shape to be
a square because that's clean.
So whenever I have a
unique color, which is one
that I know has to
be on the boundary,
I'm going to make
it a flat thing.
And then I know in this
series of reductions,
I should draw this
because it's kind of fun.
So far I kind of started
with rectangle packing.
I guess technically we
started with 3-partition.
I'll draw it like this.
We reduce that to
edge-matching puzzles.
Then we reduce that to
signed edge-matching puzzles.
Then we reduced that
to jigsaw puzzles.
And if you follow this
series of reductions
and see what you get, we
know that the boundary shape
will be a square because that
frame gadget is a square.
And if we make all the
unique things flat,
then the shape will
actually be square.
There's a reason I'm drawing
it this way, because we
have another one.
So the next puzzle--
you might ask well,
if Eternity II was an
edge-matching puzzle,
what was Eternity I?
Well, it's something called
a polyform packing puzzle.
These are-- if you take
an equilateral triangle
and cut in half like
that, that's a shape.
If you take k copies
of that shape,
join them edge to edge
along matching edge lengths,
you can get all these shapes.
It's like Tetris, but
instead of the squares
you start with that shape and
you join a bunch more of them
together.
I don't know exactly how many.
They may not even be
all the same area.
And your goal is to fit
inside this big dodecagon
or something.
This was solved.
One million pounds were
acquired by two people.
I think they were
mathematicians,
Alex and Oliver, in 2000.
So actually quite soon
after the puzzle was posed,
I think within less than a year.
So there were articles about how
the insurance company was not
happy.
That's why you get insured
against a puzzle being solved,
I guess.
But in Eternity II, as a
consequence, it is much harder.
So no one had solved
it yet, but it
will happen someday I'm sure.
So this gives you a clear sense
of what the shapes look like.
So I want to prove these puzzles
are NP-hard also by reduction
from jigsaw puzzles.
So let's just bring
up the picture.
So we just did this reduction.
It actually works in both ways.
They're really the same puzzle.
This does not work so
easily in both ways.
But I'm going to
take a jigsaw piece.
I'm going to turn it into
roughly a square made up
of little squares.
I'm not going to work
on the half triangles,
although I think it
wouldn't be any harder.
It's a lot easier to
think about square puzzles
more like Tetris.
These are polyominos.
So polyomino packing
is this type of puzzle.
They also exist, but no one
has won one million pounds
from them.
So that's why I showed Eternity.
So almost a square, but then
in the middle of the edge
we're going to write in binary
what this shape was here.
I mean, if there was a color
over here and a shape here,
all we care about is whether
they're the same or different.
So there's only 4n
different colors out there.
So we're going to
take log of 4n bits
and write them in this way.
And if it was indented,
whenever we have a 1,
we're going to indent here.
And if it's a tab instead of a
pocket, wherever we have a 1,
we're going to outdent.
OK.
So these are all
different codes.
And so none of them fit
together, for example.
And let's see.
Does anything match up?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: This one
matches with this one,
because if I rotate it around,
stick it on, it will match up.
So you have to make sure you get
the orientations to the codes
all right, but you can do this.
And two things will
fit together and make
a nice clean seem, if and only
if the original colors matched.
And so this
represents that puzzle
where we've blown everything
up by like a logarithmic factor
in each dimension.
But the number of pieces is
staying the same, in a sense.
So that was this reduction
to polyomino packing.
For fun, we close the loop, and
reduce from polyomino packing
to edge-matching in this way.
So we're going to
take our polyomino,
carve it up into
little squares, turn
them into edge-matching puzzle.
And here I actually
want to allow rotation,
so I'm going to change these
colors to all percent signs.
And now it's just the
same puzzle again.
So we have to use
the frame again.
And so if you want,
you could just
keep following these reductions
over and over and over.
I think every time you do it,
you increase the scale factor
by like a log factor.
But it's kind of fun.
I mean, it really
shows these puzzles
are very close to
identical in that
we didn't have to blow up
the puzzle size by very much
to go from one
puzzle to the next.
So usually we're just thinking
about polynomial blow up here.
We have a very small
notion of blowup,
which is some tight sense
in which these puzzles are
almost the same.
OK.
End of paper.
A fun open problem
is this reduction
used log n by log n-- order
log n by log n pieces.
What if your pieces
only have area log n?
So maybe they're root log n by
root log n or something that.
I'm sure it should still be in
NP-hard, but you never know.
For example, they're
constant size.
Actually, well, let's say,
if they're size 2, its easy.
Leave it at that even if
the shape is very messy.
But if there are also 2
by 2 blocks it's easy.
So clearly small
shapes are too easy.
But probably logarithmic
area is where
it starts to get interesting.
I don't know.
What about log, log area?
That's probably neither NP-hard
nor polynomial, but oh, well.
Cool.
So I want to talk about one
more problem-- one more hardness
proof in this similar vein.
It's about packing.
I already erased
packing rectangles
into rectangles or
rectangles into a square.
What about squares
into a square?
I don't know if you can tell
if that's a square and not
a rectangle.
OK.
This is a nice paper.
We've used it for other hardness
proofs, which we'll probably
talk about next class.
So I'm given a bunch of squares,
and I'm given a target square.
Do these squares fit in there?
And again, we will
probably use exact-- well,
initially we won't
be exact packing.
But let's say that
the squares can only
rotate by a multiple of 90.
In other words,
they can't rotate.
We will fix that by
making exact packing.
Why don't I jump
to the reduction?
The heart of the reduction
is this idea-- we're just
going to add a big number here.
I am going to use capital
B for the big number.
That's what's in the paper.
This is a paper from 1990.
Motivation here is you have a
big grid supercomputer, which
were popular in
the '80s and '90s.
And you have a job, which was
a square grid of processors,
let's say.
And you want to execute
them all in parallel,
but they're not
allowed to overlap,
because that would slow
your supercomputing down.
But you are allowed
gaps, let's say.
So I'm just going to take
each of my a i numbers,
add this huge number to it.
So they're all
roughly the same size.
This is the trick we did
at the beginning of class
with the 3-partition.
All right.
All these numbers-- all these
sizes are almost the same.
I've drawn them quite different,
but imagine they're just
like tiny fluctuations.
And then I make the
height of this rectangle.
For whatever reason I
transposed my image.
That's probably why I
was confused earlier.
And I just make the height
three times the big number--
because I want three pieces
to come together-- plus t,
my target sum of the a i's.
So this is a huge thing
plus a super tiny thing.
But what it's saying is
well, you could have slop.
They're almost the
same size, but there's
that little bit of extra.
And that little bit of extra
has to add up to exactly t.
So this is one triple with
the desired target sum.
And then I want to get
n over three of them.
Now here's where things
get a little dicey.
You say, OK, let's just
say I take the largest one,
or actually I'll go all
the way up to B plus t.
I know that every number
I have is smaller than t,
because I just saw the
sum of three of them is t.
So I'm always going
to have a gap here.
And let's say I just
packed the next three there
and then the next three there.
And so I'll leave enough
room that even with the slop
I could fit everything in.
So each one is B plus t, and
the number of them is n over 3.
So that'll be the
width of my rectangle.
Looks like a lot
of slop, but that's
because I drew this with the
squares very different in size.
If we compute the
amount of slop,
the maximum, if you
look at this distance,
it's at most t, certainly.
Even if a i were 0,
which is not allowed,
then this distance would be t.
So it's going to be
even smaller than that.
But the gaps here
are always at most t.
So we can take-- so
this is total slop
is t times the height.
So that was like the width
of one sliver of slop,
and then the height
is 3B plus t.
And then times n over
3, because there's
n over 3 of those things.
And hopefully this works.
I want to say this is
less than B squared
if B is bigger than t times n.
3s cancel.
So if B is, I think
this term won't matter,
because B is going
to be bigger than t.
So maybe put a 2 there
for extra safety.
Then you're totally dwarfed.
So just dividing
both sides by B we're
getting 3 times t
times n over part 3.
That's 2 times n.
OK.
Cool.
So the point is the
total area of slop
that I have here is less
than a single square,
because a single square
is even bigger than this.
So you're not going to
be able to pack anymore
squares, and that's
a vague argument,
but enough hand-waving
later, and you've
proved that, in fact, any
packing of these squares
will give you 3-partition.
That requires more
work, but this is
some intuition why it is true.
OK.
So this was actually packing
squares into a rectangle.
But that wasn't the
problem I started with.
I wanted to pack
squares into a square.
So for that you need an
infrastructure gadget
like the frame that
we made before.
And this is kind of acute
number theory-ish trick.
I'm going to take
some integer x.
We'll choose it later.
It's just going to be big
enough-- something like n.
And we have one
giant square, which
is x times x plus 1 minus 1.
But they're all squares,
so by the same amount.
And then we're going to take
these medium-sized squares
of size x plus 1 and the
small squares-- so much
smaller-- of size x.
And because this
is just one smaller
than what it's supposed
to be-- I mean,
if it was x times x plus 1 it
would sort of come to here.
So when you pack these guys up
you go just one too far there.
But there's exactly
enough room for one more.
If I put x plus one
extra, this is x.
That's the one, and so on.
So this leaves, as
a gap, a rectangle.
Now this is not
the only solution
these guys could
slide down, but you
can show that will only
make your life harder.
And the paper does that.
That's sort of the
easy part of the proof.
And so now you're
left with a rectangle,
which is 1 by this thing.
You multiply everything
by the 3B plus t,
because that was what we
wanted one of our dimensions
to be-- the smaller one.
So that scaled up the rectangle.
And then the horizontal-- the
width may not match exactly.
But if there's too
much space here,
and let me just set
x to be large enough,
then there will be extra space.
And just throw in a
bunch of B by B blocks
there to fill up
the extra space.
So you can figure out how
much extra space there
is and fill it in.
So they you go-- packing
squares into a square.
And this is strong
NP-hardness of this.
Even when the squares are
only of polynomial area,
this problem is hard,
which is actually
the case you care about when
each of these 1 by 1 squares
is a processor.
Now this is not exact packing,
and so you might wonder oh,
what if I rotate the squares,
and then crazy things
could happen.
Probably not, but you
could also just compute
how much extra slop
there is, because you
know the area of
the input squares,
and you know the area
of the target square.
And just add a whole bunch
of 1 by 1 little chips,
and that will fill
in exactly the space.
Then you have exact packing.
Then you don't even have
to worry about rotation.
So that makes
proof even cleaner.
I think that wasn't
in the original paper,
but it's a nice little addition.
And that is our packing
through 3-partition.
Next class we'll
do more 3-partition
for different types of problems.
So in case you lose lots of
pieces in your jigsaw puzzle,
we have the one-piece
jigsaw puzzle.
This is all the pieces are
in one giant connected mess.
And still it is not
so trivial to solve.
Wow.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: All right.
This is the one-piece jigsaw
puzzle in solve state.
It's the Simpson's addition.
It's-- you get it.
AUDIENCE: [INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: And then
you put that in.
And then you put
it in your slop.
AUDIENCE: Yep. [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Ta-da.